il a été libéré la semaine prochaine pour bonne
conduite
la seule chose c'est qu'il a besoin d'un travail c'est
ton [ __ ] de frère ne te trompe pas
mec je m'en fous de nous papa non
qu'est ce qui ne va pas avec vous
me fait chier de ne pas faire ces conneries
les emplois me font chier de te voir à un
[ __ ] de bureau et tu veux changer
quelque chose je ne me donne pas cette merde
bien tu ne peux pas changer ta poubelle au
tribunal enlever le premier commentaire même en
prison j'ai eu des biscuits
[ __ ] j'ai menti
il  Est-ce que mes cheveux avaient
raison, pourquoi changerais-tu jamais
Je te rendrai si [ __ ] de heureuse tu
dis
quand ton frère a une réputation très bruyante
Je lui ai passé le dos juste
parce que
je vais bien  fais attention